they don't really exist it's so funny
because it's like all the women will
come forward and like you know it's like
we're all [__] all of us because yeah
no 90s no no seriously because 96 of us
will be thrown out a hundred years ago
yeah I got a one percent wife I'm cool
with it
how do we not know that maybe they're
not married like she's not a virgin on
their wedding day but maybe she only had
sex with that guy okay 90
like it's like okay
we'll give another another five but it's
still nine out of 10 of us would be
thrown out a hundred years ago so I mean
can men expect that in 2023 it I don't
say this happily you know but not really
well then when you have a social media
life that is brought on to 20 something
year old women who are at the age of
insecurities marriage and insecurities
they're going to Veer themselves into a
a pond that maybe they're not even in to
like all of these women who are going
into uh uh
selling their bodies one out of 25 one
out of 25 under the age of 35 cells oh
I'm sure I'm sure I want to talk about
that I want to talk about it I would
think it's even more than that you're
like this well yeah that's just kaminal
minutes but my philosophy is mental was
pay for it yup yeah and that's why when
there's so that is one out of 25 selling
or or all of them I think it's more than
that if you're married you're paying for
it if you're married you have to have
resources if you have a girlfriend you'd
have to Resource if you're dating
hookers if you have a transactional
relationship and paying for it so maybe
one out of 25 has a transactional
situation but I believe all men pay and
the guys that don't just like a guy says
I'd never pay for it oh she did it for
free well I wouldn't want to be with a
girl that's free because that that
there's no value if she says oh come
over and watch Netflix and we'll have
sex dude that's easy that who wants to
be with that so look at it from this
perspective if for thousands of years
men or women always went for guys with
resources right yeah Dr David Buss in
his book uh evolution of desire and if
that's the case
we have to establish those resources
that costs us money I think there's a
distinction though between uh paying for
it and just being a guy who's of you
know decent Network a decent net worth
and he can he can provide interesting
experiences like I've talked to the
Tates about it I talked to no there is I
talked to Tristan about this and and and
and they had have or had a lot of money
right and he would date women and he
said but it's not like it's not like you
say to the one right come out and I'm
gonna you know I'll give you five grand
for the weekend it's not that but but it
is hey I've got this cool car we can
take a trip we go down to Italy we'll be
by the beach we'll go to this cool
restaurant blah blah blah so they're
providing the money allows you to
provide an interesting experience but
it's not necessarily but I agree there
are degrees of transactionality and all
of this stuff but that that you don't
have to be you know Tristan take style
multi-millionaire for that to happen
though they're on a on a lower level
there's a lot of girls who they want to
go on trips
I think I think the whole point is that
you know just as women we make kind of
dumb decisions so here put that up again
please yeah
you know and that's what I was thinking
about I'm like yeah it's better like and
I was thinking about I was thinking
about how nowadays like under five is
the new version and I was thinking about
how sad that is I'm like well as a group
I'm like as a group like the best women
in today's market it's like under five
well the best women of today's market
know that the the thing of women
shouldn't vote our whole system is
rigged to [__] begin with anyway and
any woman of value is gonna go
it doesn't even matter what's a woman of
value a woman of value knows Harry's one
of these rounds
I'd say high value is a virgin everyone
else may be somewhere a medium value but
there's no such thing as a high-valued
woman I think nowadays
so if you're well that's a quality I
think it's an energy that you give off I
think if you value yourself and you're
probably gonna go oh here she goes again
saying as she gets older she gets more
beautiful and that's [__] but if you
have an energy about you and you present
yourself to the world like I am a high
value woman not in a fake way what if
you're 300 pounds and you have less
energy yeah that's what I'm thinking I
don't think that you will have that
energy about you because you are 300
pounds well hey why are there 300 pounds
that's the question like why am I
outside
in better shape than I was when I was
24. so I have that energy about me at 37
because I'm in bed
yourself like the top 10 20 of women I
would say the top 30 okay top 30 because
when I think of like High I mean we
could say quality even even doing that
well but someone are better than others
right
a lot of that has to do with my
intellect but there's no but that's how
it looks yeah but guys
there's a rule in the exception right so
the looks and this is what yeah I saw
you responded that post and I get it
yeah when I said feelings it's like if I
ask a woman how she rates herself it's
like well I didn't even write my no no
no no I know but I feel I'm a I'm a
eight or a nine or ten this or that and
it's like no your looks just your looks
yeah and then they start giving you this
long answer I didn't give you a long
time are you the group of girls I didn't
give myself an Aiden or nine or two okay
I didn't even do that and all I'm saying
is I gain knowledge as I got older and
that that benefits
it's like no I'm serious I'm seriously
like think about this I want a girl that
knows a lot
[Music]
of scratch that one off well my thing is
yeah but would you be it would long term
you you think you're smarter or you
think you're wiser and uh as the time
has gone on yes as you've gotten older
you think you're worth it guys aren't
gonna think what like why would a guy
think you're worth it without your
opinion but that's an exception without
your opinion because that's your opinion
of yourself is one thing you guys
opinion of someone else so clearly
something is working that look at the
rig as well no but
that's subjective in a sense where
divorce rates are still high of course
so Troy I got a question so of course
when you're you're coaching man that are
oh go ahead oh and I was gonna say over
the age of 35 you only have like a 15
chance of getting down the aisle yeah so
like you you could be the exception but
you're not the rule I mean I don't
totally understand yeah yeah and I I
agree with that so Troy when you're
coaching and mentoring these guys and
dating
um do you run into this a lot with these
guys looking for these pretty women and
the challenges they're having and what
they're running into because what I'm
seeing now no no what I'm what I'm
seeing now is the scales adjusted with
time
because of all the attention from the
social media that we're seeing yeah
right the female attention necessity
disorder that coin phrase right that
none of the the psychologists will take
but all the attention they're getting
they're so used to attention when the
pandemic hit everybody had these mental
disorders because they weren't getting
the attention outside so they got them
online and I'm an eight I'm a ten I'm a
10. and then they don't date anybody
because all because there's only a few
percentage of guys that have that
ability I think I think there's a few
things I think yeah overall I think it's
become it's become tougher I think it's
become flakier you know even if you're
talking to a girl on a dating app or you
may run the coffee shop or whatever then
yeah you know you should definitely
gonna come out and meet you or maybe she
you know the next bright shiny object
comes along but on the other hand these
girls still want to meet people they
still want to get laid do you know what
I mean I think it also gets a little I
think it'll hell yeah
I think it gets a little bit overstated
as well I mean you can still go out
there and make things happen but equally
there's a lot of distractions for these
women and you know that there is an
element of this stuff happening for sure
you know if she's getting hit up by you
know the bloke with the the yacht the
blow the geyser with the yacht in Miami
and she's you know that's gonna color
her sense of her own values well and I
realized too that like we're basically
like men addicted to poor and all of us
with social media
are basically also addicted to social
media it's like the equivalent of a guy
addicted to totally and I know this
because it's like and I see the
propaganda working firsthand because I
like talk to girls on my show and it's
like they all say the same thing they
don't even know what they're saying yeah
like even like when I think of
horoscopes it's like what do we do why
are we talking about it's funny too
because I found myself desensitized to
to Instagram when Instagram first came
out it was like way back in 07 or
something or 05 and it was a few
pictures oh nine I think it was I
remember seeing I posted a picture and
now it became this real thing but I
remember when the reels kicked off you
you'd go to your search bar if you go to
all your search bars you're like whoa
look at this chick look at this chick
now I see it I'm like oh my God you're
so desensitized to it whereas in 10
years ago you'd have been popping a
party in two seconds to it right
it's all done on purpose so and that's
to be popular well don't you respect
that we're we're populate us there's a
depopulation agenda happening and they
do not want people procreating with one
another what's the problem with the porn
that's part of what the abortion is
we're also 10 years older though we're
also because we want things AI girls
soon the tits are gonna be so good and
that waist is going to be so small
they're not going to want real women
okay hold on hold on oh my god look mom
like men are gonna take [__] yes
they do that as a response because
sexism
they will want that but they're also
going to probably take robots right but
my whole thing is like they're doing
that because women have these crazy high
standards but that's all an agenda but I
understand soon it's an agenda but I
don't I think like we're disagreeing on
like how it started like I'm saying
women have these high standards the men
are sexless so they go to porn what's a
response to us real quick David what
would you do if you were single right
now single right now I'd Focus solely on
becoming the best version of yourself
this is what I do in my life so I'm
affiliate marketer but my main thing I'm
doing now is I'm a life coach I get guys
discipline with their mind body and
spirit specifically like my biggest
advice as this whole topic was porn that
was like the one thing in my life I was
married in watching porn wife didn't
even know about it and there was a
disconnect in a relationship I stopped a
year ago correct right I stopped a year
ago and I waited three four months
before I started coaching anybody until
I could heal myself yeah I told my wife
that and she said that's why we that's
why I thought you didn't think I was
attractive no she's bomb the problem was
the problem was I was desensitized like
you said yeah I didn't think it was bad
I would always use it as a crutch just
like oh I'm so busy with business with
work I just go like rub one off don't
even think about it and then I saw like
how messed up it was I was like
withholding it weird way I was talking
to Glenn about it yesterday I was like I
use it as like a withholding method I
didn't even realize it yeah and as soon
as I stopped officially like I could
walk into a room like in Vegas I don't
get swayed at all I feel like I'm in a
certain it's crazy certain realm it's so
crazy how you walk down the street here
I was like they're allowed to just have
their boobs out
we're waiting for you to do that
I was just like I was walking down the
street I would say pearl to do that